[Music]
every night this week we'll be bringing
you a piece of our series tech tyranny
we're covering the ways that powerful
tech companies are dominating American
life in a way that has never happened
before in American history
most people are ignoring it they
shouldn't be it's changing everything
Amazon's power over data is so great now
that even the US military is seeking
their help within a few weeks the
Defense Department is expected to
request a ten billion dollar contract
that will allow Amazon to become the
sole provider of cloud computing
services to the military what does this
mean a story we're not going to ignore
Matt stores that fellow with citizens
against monopolies and he joins us
tonight Matt this is one of those
stories that like a lot of stories right
now they're just kind of passing people
by and no one's stopping you say well
what is this and one of the implications
of it so let me ask what is this and one
of the implications of this so so this
is what the Pentagon calls a potential
revolution in how they buy information
technology and information technology is
the heart of everything right now yes
including war so this is a decision by
the the Pentagon or potential decision
by the Pentagon to do something very
unusual which is to not have multiple
suppliers of a key resource that they
rely on in this case data and they are
handing over an important bottleneck of
our national security to Jeff Bezos and
Amazon and that's something that should
be very concerning to people because
Jeff Bezos has relationships Amazon has
relationships all over the world with
all sorts of entities that could that
have a reason to manipulate and
undermine American national security
interests and even if they don't even if
Amazon does a great job and we have no
other redundant cloud computing services
last year because of a typo in an Amazon
datacenter a whole bunch of websites
150,000 websites went down including big
ones like Pinterest parts of slack and
even the Securities and Exchange
Commission so it is a really dangerous
thing to award a contract over such a
vital resource to just one company and
the pentagon needs to split this among
multiple cloud computing service
companies so that there's some basic
redundancy and so that Jeff Bezos is not
the sole guy who's in charge of this
company that has
relationships with foreign governments
that we don't fully understand as you
pointed out this seems nuts why would we
do something like this what would the
Pentagon do something like this hey no
it's like a bad movie plot or something
like that I mean what's the first thing
that you're gonna do if you get into a
war with the United States you know you
would undermine the Pentagon's ability
to access its data and if there's only
one provider of data if it's just Amazon
AWS it's much easier to do that than if
you have multiple sources of supply it's
just basic national security strategy so
I'm not exactly sure what the Pentagon
is thinking I think they're probably
multiple different power centers in the
Pentagon that are thinking about this
they might believe that you know Amazon
if you just awarded all the one company
that they will have the best security
but then of course if there's
penetration of that one security barrier
then you know all your eggs are in that
one basket so there's there's different
arguments for why you'd award a contract
like this to one company but it's
probably a bad idea in its contra the
long history of American national
security policy has any company had more
power in the history of this country or
any other country than Amazon or Google
ever it's a really good question I mean
I think you could you could potentially
look at Standard Oil in the 1880s and
1890s but they didn't have the ability
to profile individuals to manipulate
individuals and individual companies the
way that Jeff Bezos and the way that
Larry Page does so it's hard it's hard
to say but this is this is crazy they
could control your energy but they had
no control over your mind some seems a
big difference to me Matt store thank
you for paying attention to this well
most people aren't appreciate it thanks
for having me